our state's kova task force says we are
in the midst of a surge that we haven't
seen since november of 2020 that tested
our hospital capacity at that time but
because our state has taken measures to
reduce the spread we aren't seeing the
surges that other states are dwayne
young points to the raiders events where
vaccinations have been required and
verified as one example he says they'll
continue to push for that
i know individuals were concerned and
upset well we didn't move the remask in
time for the holidays but we are already
prepared and we slowed our surge
compared to the rest of the country
because we kept those mitigation
measures in place
he adds that the world of concrete and
many other conventions are still on
schedule because our state has been
working to keep us and visitors safe the
health department recommends you get
vaccinated and booster and wear your
mask
here in clark county we are flagged for
high covert transmission as mentioned
the current case rate is 370 per 100 000
individuals we have been working toward
getting that number below 50.
per the state's goal but it did spike
over the last week or so our test
positivity rate is now sitting at 11.1
percent that is up from 10.1 yesterday
well on the national scale numbers
continue trending upward the u.s
averages more than 277 thousand new
coveted cases a day health officials say
being vaccinated and boosted gives
people the best chance against omicron
well the rate